I remember sitting outside
going "I'm screening my third feature
and I'm losing my house?" I was sitting at
my kitchen table with
my wife writing some very big checks to
lots of lawyers and I said
"If something doesn't change you know we
could lose everything?" And she's like
"Well we don't have money." And I said "Well
we can't let that stop us.
Don't let that stop us." So I got hit with
just dozens and dozens of thousands of
dollars in debt and I think was eighty
thousand at one point. And I had a check
in my hand, I went to the bank and it
bounced and then the person disappeared
This happened twice. You know if I have to rob a
bank to get the money to make this movie
I hope I can shoot it before I go to
trial. So I stayed up Wednesday, Thursday,
Friday straight. I don't know how I did
it and we even had this idea that we
would make a feature just her and I this
didn't pan out but they did enough
damage where half of our crew was scared
and they left and I'm talking about like
I went down like it was like all the
pain or motion that I was suppressing
kind of just came out it devastated me
so much that I I I didn't know if it was
worth it keep going because you're
passionate you're gonna get it done you
know
but it's not painless if I like it I'll
give you a year's contract if I don't
like it you're up the street you can't
come back to this job you got to ask
yourself do you want to make a small
little indie film or do you want to have
a job and I was like I want to make a
small little indie film piece I can do a
job I really don't want to do and make
OK money or I could do exactly what I
want to do and push myself and that was
a scary scary risk walking around any
part of the city with 14,000 dollars
worth of equipment a girl all by myself
with one eye covered and earphones on
and can't see behind me and you kind of
block out at the same time this wow this
could be over like that at one point I
think I calculated it was like it sorry
once it got like over like 150 nose or
so I just I stopped counting as I look
back I'm thankful that he said no cuz
hey he made that for his film I would
never cry to get on the sadness not to
direct I would push the button and see
what it does and then whatever that
whatever it did I would just write that
down
out of the 50 plus movies you've
directed and produced which was the
hardest to find financing for well I
would definitely say the first one she's
gonna have it which costs $175,000
because that was my debut film as far as
a feature film as future films go and
people think that I did that film right
at the film school there was a four year
period between me finishing in weiu and
she could have it coming out so it was
not like that and then another one would
be a Malcolm X we ran out of money in
they had to go get some money to does it
ever get easier what's easy what's easy
I mean it was easy you know I wouldn't
be I wouldn't launched a Kickstarter
campaign
it's just weird day five so mr. tough
business you know you know that's and I
really an e can tell you he's one of my
students and every time I'm here in LA
he helps me but I'm not trying to
sugarcoat things all to my students and
it'll be a great disservice to them if I
did that so I let them know you know
this this is no guarantee it's gonna
happen for you it was kind of a weird
situation because once this happened it
was about a year before the movie
happened which is actually pretty quick
but it feels strange in that situation
to sort of wait for all of these things
and not knowing if it's real if it's
actually gonna happen or not because
during this year it was you know signing
with a management firm and an agency and
all that and then finding a writer
working with the writer to develop a
script and making a deal for all this
with you know getting a lawyer and all
that so
during this year left and I we didn't
know if this was actually real or if it
was all bullshit so we were like well we
can't stop going so we kept making
shorts um you know around our house
where we could come up with little new
ideas we made one in the Attic one in
the basement and just try and come up
with new stuff and you know for each of
these shorts I would make these a little
behind the scenes videos that was that
turn out to be very appreciated by
people who saw this like other
up-and-coming filmmakers and it was
something I did just because I loved
that's what I wanted to see I wanted to
see you know I've always loved seeing
behind the scenes and making of x' and
all these because you know just to learn
as much as possible and see what it's
like on a film set and how do you create
these things and all that so we just
kept doing that and we even had this
idea that we would make a feature just
her and I this didn't pan out but then
in March something like that of 2015
they basically saw yeah movies is
happening we need you here like next
week or whatever so look uh basically
had to quit her job because you were
working in a group home you know I was a
freelance animator so I didn't have
anything steady going so we basically
you know locked our apartment got on a
plane and this was you paid for by the
studio because we were broke like when
we first got a manager you know they
were like hey can you get out here
because we want you to meet all these
people and go like on this you know tour
of Hollywood's like oh hey this is this
guy and whatever but we didn't have any
money so it's like yeah we can't do that
but then they pay for us to have to fly
out here and yeah it was very strange we
we had to find a place to live here and
it's everything is super expensive in LA
but we found on it and Airbnb this half
a garage in Burbank it was sort of
parted into two so this mother and her
daughter were our neighbors in this
garage it was like I mean for us it was
like
two and a half grand or something I'm
Martha Russ that is insane yeah I I mean
it was a pretty nice garage I mean it
wasn't bad or anything but it was quite
a shock to find out how expensive it was
and we still didn't have any money and
when we got over here you have a studio
paid for the flight over and everything
and they were gonna pay for living
expenses but not until it was greenlit
and it wasn't actually greenlit until
quite late so we had to I mean first of
all we borrowed from everyone we knew
back home in Sweden and then that money
went out with it's like new what do we
do now so we had to borrow from the
producer and they're like a manager and
it was kind of dicey because it was like
well as this doesn't happen we're in
deep shit because we're like all
borrowed out when it comes to money but
then thankfully it did happen in the
movie but yeah it was all pretty crazy
because I had never been on a movie set
before so the first time I actually
stepped foot on a real movie set it was
asked the director oh it's pretty crazy
I mean especially because I mean
everyone there had more experience than
me and every assistant your PA and like
they've all done worked on real movies
and I you know and and part of me think
you know I think they kind of thought I
was more experienced than I was and you
know I wasn't gonna correct them it's
like yeah sure you wanna want me to make
your movie well but you know they would
ask me if oh do you have a DP you work
with or an editor or a storyboard artist
and it was just no I've done all these
things myself because I've had to you
know I don't think I'm more gifted or
smarter than anyone else I just want to
do it bad enough and this goes back to
what I was saying before I create my own
opportunities I'm not gonna wait for
someone to say oh now we're gonna let
you make this movie I figure out a way
to do it whether and I've always said
this whenever I go into a movie
especially movie like Steel City I said
I'm gonna make this for 30,000 or
300,000 I'm gonna make this movie and I
think once you do that and you create
the sense of urgency and you you're
moving forward people more people start
to hop on but I'm no smarter than it or
more I think there's a lot of passionate
people I hear who
ashin about acting or passionate and who
want to do this and they're convinced
this is their life that's great but if
you're really convinced this is your
life
then you have to make it your life make
it a career and I have made this I made
the promise to myself that I would never
give up I will continue doing it despite
whatever setbacks hey if I've got to go
get another day job you know cleaning
carpet or working in a warehouse I'll do
that that's fine but I'm never going to
abandon what I feel such an essential
part of who I am as a person what I can
offer what I you know I think given a
bigger scale getting given a bigger
canvas
whether it's Hollywood and I think
you've actually I'm gonna get there I'll
be able to do something that's going to
really affect you know have me say
something to you know to reach a wide
audience but I don't I'm not entitled
that's why I keep doing these small
movies and figuring it out because you
know I really feel that one day I'll be
in a position to reach a wide audience
and when that happens when they say
where did this guy come from they'll say
oh he's been doing all this stuff he's
been working he's been developing his
craft to get here you know and that's
what I'm doing and I need help and I
need the support of people and I need
crews and great actors and everyone to
come to the thing but I also am
sensitive and I think a lot of people
don't realize this - who come out here
they have to get something out of it -
this isn't the Brian John party and this
isn't the whomever the Bill Jones party
or whatever they got to get something
out of it - whether you write you do
your due diligence and you write a great
script that people that actors are
really gonna like and you raise money to
pay your crew or if you don't have money
to pay your crew you hire people who are
willing to work for certain amount you
know you you have to figure out what
your resources are some people have a
lot of resources some people have no
resources and it's not fair I'm here to
tell you it is not fair some people have
a lot of resource they have a lot of
money they have at their dad's in the
entertainment business there some
Richard they give all you know it's not
fair this is not a fair game out here
it's just and if people come out here
thinking it's a fair playing field then
they're in for a rude awakening the key
is to figure out what your resources are
what you have access to and to make the
best of it and if you're able to do that
sooner or later I feel like your
resources are gonna grow and the your
outreach are going to grow but if you
spend all your time wallowing in the
fact that you don't have what someone
else has or their outreach or their come
there their ability to get more money or
get more exposure that's the way then
you're already done in the water because
that's the way it's always going to be
period it's not level it's not a fair
playing field out here in LA yeah in LA
in particular I think that applies to
life but in the entertainment business
it's certainly not a fair playing field
at all I mean you know how do you
explain movie stars kids starring in
movies couldn't they if I'm sure there's
another young actor who's probably just
as good or better but no you know it's
nepotism it's who you know and and I
think that works for a while until it
doesn't and a lot of deserving people
who work their asses off do not get
opportunities because they're pushed out
of the club because they don't know
enough people but you know you know I'm
under the mentality I'm gonna fight you
know I'm the I'm the guy that's standing
in line waiting for the guy in the club
to who's been there so long he either he
dies or he he goes to a different club
you know unlike a life you know I you
know whatever happens with me in my life
in my career you know I'm not going away
I'm just I'm gonna keep doing this I
honestly thought and I was obsessed I
was like I thought I I convinced myself
I was going to die if I didn't make the
movie I thought I was going to get
struck by a fatal disease if I didn't
figure out a way to make the movie that
I would I would
either happen now we're like I just
pictured myself like laying on my
deathbed thinking I didn't make Steel
City I didn't have the guts and I didn't
I didn't do it and I just told myself I
said if this movie kills me I have to
get it made and you know if I if i bug
you know if I have to rob a bank to get
the money to make this movie I hope I
can shoot it before I go to trial and
that's the Stipe of stuff I was thinking
like I was obsessed with it and I think
that that can be a turn-off but when
you're young and you're passionate you
can you kind of have some leeway you
can't really on your fifth film like you
know you're not a kid anymore I mean
that you know I'm gonna turn 35 this
year so you have to like be a little bit
more strategic but when you're young and
you know I think you know I was just
I mean obsessed I thought I was gonna
lose my life if I didn't get to film
eight I mean sits not an understatement
I thought if I don't get the film made I
was gonna commit suicide that's how
obsessed I was seriously I mean there
was not one piece of distribution in
place when we put our money together to
make dark girls we were passionate about
this topic because both of us met my co
partner Tim berry we had are both
dark-skinned black men who have faced
the prejudice of being dark complected
in our own community and we saw members
of our family little girls from
five six seven eight nine ten years old
going through this pain being called
monkey ape darkie gorilla face ugly and
asking their mothers can they be
bleached lighter because they were ugly
and the parents trying to say so he said
no let's see what happens and so we made
the film when we cut a trailer the
trailer online and I got 2.3 million
global hits and we said we have
something we have something so let's see
if we can get a touring company to they
did got a touring company tourists
around and we're country and different
parts of the world and the success was
really great still having the
distribution and so we said okay let's
get a broker maybe yo a Booker and maybe
the Booker can set up some screenings
well how much is it gonna cost us as
we're going into the costs for the
Booker to maybe say 5 or 6 a.m. in these
theaters or something man between the
booking and the promotion and Kenneth
we're dry good run until film fuzzles
and so on
get a call on the phone Oprah Winfrey's
interested in you guys screening the
film for her okay send it to Scott over
there and it's got looked at it brought
it to Oprah's office saw it and he said
what's your lawyers name and what's that
happen is it was a I'm not gonna lie man
I knew it was a paint it was painful man
some days you wanted to say forget it
man give up what about it was painful
and what was the time frame are we
talking about year and a half I mean
you're talking about you know your your
your bank account is dry and you got
bills to pay and your accountants pissed
at you to the degree of your you really
are something's wrong with you you spent
this money for your mortgage this year
and where is that gonna come from you're
crazy you're and you start thinking
crazy and then divine intervention it or
if you want to call it says you're
you're doing something that we want you
to do so we're gonna help you when that
happens it's like first time we take a
deep breath in a long time
but you can't give up you just it's that
it's it's it's this the blessing and
curse of this industry you know you it's
it's a blessing and a curse I mean you
keep going because you're passionate
you're gonna get it done you know but
it's not painless and then when someone
sees what you see and they have
distribution and they say it has value
tears and I don't mean the polite time
Yunus the snotty type you know that kind
of stuff that really just thankful as
you know the crude lawsuit was very
draining emotionally financially
psychologically and actually I was in
2010 and there was one day I was sitting
at my kitchen table with my wife writing
some very big checks to lots of lawyers
and you know and I said if something
doesn't change you know we could lose
everything
luckily things did change and you know I
emerged from crude from that lawsuit you
know okay but I had become disillusioned
about whether documentaries can really
affect change and if this is the price
you have to pay maybe I need to rethink
my career but then that year was
bookended beautifully in August of 2011
a year exactly a year later from that
day where I was writing all these big
checks it was announced that the West
Memphis Three were getting out of prison
and of course the film's you know the
Paradise Lost series played a big role
in that because it was kind of those
films you know well I don't want to take
full credit or even anything close to
that because a lot of very unique
circumstances came together and tens of
thousands of people you know very
generously agitated for the work you
know the release of the West Memphis
Three and notable celebrities came in
and you know a unique set of
circumstances came together to release
the West Memphis Three or to put
pressure on the authorities but the
films were the catalyst for that and so
after having had a horrible year getting
clobbered in my loss
suit against Chevron I had you know the
opposite experience where I saw the
power of documentaries that you know
films can effect positive social change
that they had a deep impact on on the
West Memphis Three case and thankfully
that renewed my spirit and I got out of
my doldrums and I you know carried on
and so the next big project that came
along was the Whitey Bulger film and you
know luckily CNN Films encouraged me to
make that film and so I did not have to
struggle for financing on that one CNN
you know paid for it so it wasn't really
so much about the money it was more
about the emotional fortitude it
requires to make these kinds of films to
enter into these kinds of worlds the
battles you have to undertake to you
know get your story out there and after
the crude experience and you know I had
I had a little bit of the life drained
out of me but thankfully with the
release of the West Memphis Three I'm
back in business
and then May decided two men decided to
make the whitey bulger film I got
offered to direct like two feature films
before a compound fracture and they both
fell through and I was just like such a
heartbreaking experience to get it all
the way to where they even wrote me a
check and I had a check in my hand I
went to the bank and it bounced and then
the person disappeared
happened twice in fact one time I
actually was at the bank with the person
while it bounced and I got so upset with
this person this was like maybe four or
five years ago I just let him have it I
lost it I like snapped everything that I
had had difficulties with at that point
culminated into this moment and I just
snapped on this guy I feel bad now but I
was like a twenty five or twenty
six-year-old kid and I made this 47 year
old gentleman cry in the bank I felt
certain victory because I actually told
him what I needed to hear but at the
same time I felt a little bit bad about
that because I had reached a point where
whatever it was that was going on pushed
me to the point where I was doing that
and I felt like maybe this business
ain't for me
I don't know if I want to become a
person that can do this kind of thing
and I felt bad about it for a while but
I realized that I look back on and I'm
like man that guy really screwed me
though I spent so much time I have so
many people favors to get this guy's
movie made and I was gonna direct it and
it fell through and everybody got
screwed sucked I felt really bad about
it
so the guy did kind of deserve it and as
much as I feel bad about that and I've
kind of like morally felt a little bit
you know regretful but I said some of
the things I said to that guy I learned
from that experience and I think I
understood that it's gonna be hard if
not impossible to get what you want out
of this business unless you really have
the ability to push through those
moments when it's the hardest thing for
you in a world and you feel like just
crushed if you can push past that I
think you have what it takes to stay in
this industry I've had friends that have
fallen off and I don't blame one bit I
feel like I kind of wish I didn't fall
off at one point cuz I've had to go
through some pretty intense experiences
in my life as a result of choosing this
career path but you know then you look
at it like well at least I'm gonna yeah
at least I'm doing what I love and I can
and I'm safe you know I have a lot of
friends that are in the military and
they have to do things that threaten
their life every day but they still do
it and if they got if those guys can do
it and they're in their heart they're
willing to put forth that kind of effort
you know what I have my problems in my
life for so minuscule compared to that
and I can't even compare it and it's
just like you know you start to think
about things like that and you're like
of course I'm gonna keep going why not
you know I mean it's just like a
everybody like there's always somebody
else out there that's got a lot worse
than you do so just gotta remember that
there are police driving around South
Los Angeles like there are like you know
buses going by in Hollywood just
constant presidents insane with the
helicopters and I never really felt like
anything was gonna happen to me if I
aimed camera as long as I'm not
antagonizing anyone so yeah and as far
as being afraid in that area I think
that's kind of like a two-fold question
because I know that the the crime rate
is higher there so that's in my mind
while I'm there but it also if I'm
walking around any part of the city with
14,000 dollars worth of equipment a girl
all by myself with one eye covered and
earphones on and can't see behind me you
know I'm always gonna feel a little edgy
you know so I definitely was I would say
more on edge than I would be but it's
hard to determine because I feel like
I'm a little ballsy in that sense like
especially if I'm trying to tell a story
that's not about me and for I believe a
greater cause that I'll put myself into
situations that are you know worth worth
not my life but you know my life
I definitely got people stopping me on
the street to ask about about the the
equipment and what I'm doing and I got a
lot of support to sister out in the hood
with my you know with my gear and like
hey tell my story tell my story you know
it's like you got any listen to my story
I got a lot of that to like okay let me
take notes I might but I'm busy right
now I can't do your story give me your
information buddy
a lot of support out there I think
people I thought it was actually really
great to be sort of an example in South
LA of like not only just like a black
woman or mixed woman making a movie as
an example in the area where there's no
film school that I know of in South LA
and then also being female and hopefully
empowering other women that even if
they're not gonna be a filmmaker just
seeing someone do something that looks
like out of the box or something that we
don't see regular regularly that I I
think that it definitely was inspiring
for for people to see my best friend
growing up is this guy Brandon Barrera
and we he's a big business savvy guy and
I'm the big creative guy and we he
convinced me to buy to go in with him
and buy this house so we bought a house
in Hollywood this was you know I had
money from Peter Pan and some other
acting jobs and we had this house and
then I got into making this movie and
I'm like Brandon how about we do a
production company sell the house
finance the movie he said sure let's do
it
we financed the movie two years later
I'm broke I learned about something
called capital gains tax you shouldn't
know about that before you sell house
kids so I got hit with just dozens and
dozens of thousands of dollars in debt
and I think was eighty thousand at one
point and you know I was worried about
having to I had the LLC for the movie
and we had this production company and I
went to work and I was I moved into this
apartment that I called the hovel and
lived there worked every single night
where where were you I was working at
the village idiot on Melrose and Martel
okay which is great barn these the guys
who owned the bar they had just sunk
everything they had into opening this
bar and I would come into work every
morning to pick up my tips like right as
they opened and one day my boss was like
Blaine tell me the truth do you have a
drug problem and I'm like what what do
you what do you mean he's like nobody
needs 80 bucks so bad that they get here
at 9:00 a.m. he's like what's the deal
and I told him I just I just spent
everything I
and a lot that I don't to make this
movie and he's like well I just did that
for this restaurant so we were in this
same situation exactly and we kind of
became great friends they were always
work work me let me do overtime to get
Elektra money and very frowned on the
restaurant world but they you know we're
such supporters ironically not
ironically we've become very close to me
and those guys and the after party for
the LA premiere of cut to the chase
we'll be at the village idiot which oh
that's great I love synchronicity but
yeah so I was work writing every day I
get up early in the morning and I'd
write and I wrote four or five scripts
that year the year of the Havel and like
it was literally almost exactly a year
cuz right as the lease was running out
weather girl came together I was able to
get out of there I got paid a proper fee
to direct you know and I got to direct
Mark Harmon and Kaitlin Olson and Jon
Cryer and Jane Lynch it was like it was
a totally different you know experience
for me and like I there was a time where
I didn't think that would ever happen
but it was just tenacity and if I hadn't
been in the hovel I don't know if I
would have been as writing as much as I
was and I don't know if I would have
done whether girl so you know it I guess
it paid off
I'll start the story and if this is like
too much for kike if it's too much for
TV like this let me know okay but I lost
the pregnancy during pre-production Oh
so of what death leaves behind and it
was the hardest laws even though I've
lost people I didn't realize how bad
that was I didn't even hear about people
they have miscarriage and such in mine
might happen while I was I was I was put
under like I was not conscious for it
wasn't my decision it was it was one of
those things very traumatic but during
pre-production that was onset like you
know what I shouldn't have been right
after that but um yeah it was that was
so hard
but I put it away because I had a job to
do we were about to go into production
time to get moving and I did I went and
moved and we had we filmed the dream
sequences in what death leaves behind
separate from the film and they're like
our own little movie
it's different it looks different it's
weird it's a dream we chatted in Sun
Center studios in in Essen Pennsylvania
and it's very eerie and weird so we
shocked him as her own movie so we like
what really hard into it and this was
like a ye like 2016 or something and um
we shot it and right after that I had
like a little break from the crazy and
I'm talking about like I went down like
it was like all the pain or motion that
I was suppressing kind of just came out
and I wasn't used to that level of pain
because of that type of pain because I
don't suppress things people stuff comes
up I deal with it but that was different
it was like a whole nother heartstring
that was pulled so that was really tough
and then getting back into production
that's where some things had happened
with one person kind of destroying some
of the the synergy or whatever you want
to call it the the culture the the
caring nature of the set was kind of
disturbed by a person and I had to fire
them during that time there was a
producer that was kind of helping us on
some business ends that kind of did some
shady things I had to get rid of them it
was like all these things they're really
hard to deal with for anyone but I was
in this really bad space like anonyme
bad like I was depressed but it was like
my heart was like burst open like it was
very much an open wound and I knew it
and I communicated to my inner circle in
the in the group like you know like the
director knew at that point they didn't
know when it happened they knew when I
had to go back to the hospital because I
had complications from the surgery
during production I was like in the
hospital all my computer and they're
like man put the computer down like it
was like crazy time and then in the same
time I got a Fire's and one that was
really important to the production and I
had to get rid of a relationship that
would have made distribution easy
because he was shady like stuff like
that happened during that time so I
think that year of pre-production was
not even though that was the moment that
wasn't that year wasn't the hardest it
was why we were in that law and then
coming back at the production and
finishing the project it was so hard
because it was really it's just the
hardest thing to do to finish a film a
feature thing like film is the hardest
thing to do on in our industry right but
then to be dealing with some of the
hardest things I dealt with in life on
the side of my husband
using a child like that was really hard
and then like other things that pop up
you know these you know draining
situations they have nothing to do with
the movie but it has to do the people
making the movie and then things like
being aware of and I say Shady I mean
like they were doing some bad business
and I had to distance myself from that
so all these little things yeah that
made it the hardest year and I think we
all grew from it myself included like
where we would deal we we were dealing
with a lot I mean there were deaths in
we had someone in our production died
right after someone that's in the movie
so it's hard for me watch the film
because he passed away and we had a
member of the crew their grandmother
died we had my ad had to drop out during
production during the same time because
she had a family death and different
little things like that had nothing to
do with the film but those things that
come up is like are we going to lose
because of something that's not the lost
like we're going to make the film right
like we're going to keep going so we
just had to it was a moment of huge
perseverance I'll say that and it was
big perseverance like big hurdles to get
over and it was like well those things
were like you know you get over hurting
it was never that it was all right
another one another one while still
having a very personal like emotional
wound so that was that was hard and
overcoming that though lets me know on
this little film the things that we went
through and growing leaps and bounds and
getting through it and now having a
theatrical release and you know all the
things that you just can hope for
we we achieved that with all this
hopefully all that won't happen on the
next one right but also we know we can
handle it so when things happen which
they will when things pop up or things
happen to us we've already proven we can
overcome things that are really
difficult and not in like you know you
go through something it's hard and you
go to something else you're like whoa
that was nothing you know I know this
was something what we dealt with so if
we call overcome that we can keep going
if I can keep going if I can remain a
place of I can still encourage someone
that day when I just cried all night in
my two hours and I could have got some
sleep I can get through anything
anything so there's no project that I
can't confidently say to an investor I'm
going to make this film and I'm going to
get this outcome because if I said that
on this one and we got the outcome I
have to do that on anything and that's a
that's another level of confidence that
doesn't happen without adversity so if
you achieve something in a moment of
darkness how much easier is the light
how much easier is sunrise like just you
know we've got we've gotten through it
so we can do it again we can do it again
we could do it again
so in those moments of weakness or in
those moments where things are going bad
I know that I'm not going to crumble
I was in a unique situation where I was
wearing a lot of different hats so when
Joel and I were developing it we were
constantly working together so that
meant we were going out to producers we
were going out to investors we were
going out to casting agents we were
going out to anyone they would read it
they could help us put together a
package so the the challenges that
happen were that we were attaching
people that were good that were you know
friends of Joel's or just people who
liked the script and we were getting
investors that were interested and
investors that really wanted to make the
film and we're willing to option it and
put in the time but because of different
reasons they weren't able to finance it
at the end so you know sometimes
production companies will have a slate
of three films that year and one will go
way over budget and another one will get
pushed and you know there's just there's
always different reasons why financing
can fall through so unfortunately for us
that happened on three different
occasions I mean for some films it
happens 10 times 20 times 30 times you
know for other films they get financing
they move forward you know we the third
time when we lost financing within 48
hours the producer that we had attached
Taylor Hart is his name who is an
incredible producer very hungry and
driven and getting a lot of projects
done now within 48 hours of the last
time that we had our financing fall
through he found another production
and they brought all the money to the
table so with that we were able to start
pre-production the next day so we you
know we had a terrible weekend thinking
the film was once again shut down and on
Monday we were flying out to Savannah
Georgia to shoot the film so it just
every single time you try to get a film
in production or even in a
pre-production I get the financing
you're gonna find obstacles along the
way so the financing falling through was
just the very first obstacle even you
know the first day of production
actually we were working in Savannah
Georgia as I had mentioned it's a
right-to-work state we weren't unionized
across the board so of course we had sag
we were ATL unionized so everything
above the line was unionized we were sag
but some of our other departments
weren't completely unionized so I don't
know exactly which ones they were I feel
like it might have been makeup or hair
or or costume design but on the very
first day of production the unions and
the Teamsters showed up on set and we're
picketing and they told our crew that
they would have they would be fined
$5,000 for working on the film that they
would have their cards revoked that they
wouldn't work in this town again
and although that's not true because
Georgia is a right-to-work state so
technically you can shoot a film that's
not entirely unionized but they did
enough damage where half of our crew was
scared and they left and so we lost an
entire day and our production company
had to decide if they were going to pay
to unionize which is a you know
six-figure decision and if they were
gonna push production forward and for
several hours we thought that we were
gonna be shutting down completely but
luckily we had a strong production
company behind us that that paid that
difference and the wages for everyone
who is working for us became unionized
and increased and we made the film you
know so that was just another challenge
and throughout the process of production
there's challenges every single day
you know and even in the post production
it's it's a lot of creative people
working together and at the end of the
day it's it's a business so you have
different mentalities you have people
who want to create the best creative
process and and product and film and
then you have people that want to make
as much money as they possibly can so
even in post-production we have people
seeing differently you know on the same
project and we just have to find the
middle ground so that we can get it
released and and it'll be the challenges
that we have finding distribution you
know getting into the film festivals
that we want to get into and getting
into the amount of theatres and
hopefully doing well with the film so
every single corner is every single
corner and every day as a challenge and
getting a film done my case and probably
the case of every filmmaker out there
you you you see that spark and you love
it you fight and you sacrifice
everything to get there and you do it
you do it you do it
and then it doesn't quite happen the way
you think you're not plucked out of
obscurity like some of these guys are
you're still working in the trenches for
years and it's a little I can't get
frustrating and then in my case I did a
film that had a lot of controversy
around it and was never ultimately
released and it was so utterly
devastating because after so many years
of just working and working and working
sacrifice this film looked like it was
gonna really be something and then
instead he it's not released and there's
a lot of controversy and bad press in it
all his ugly things and it just it
devastated me so much that I I I didn't
know if it was worth it
and I circled the drain because it's
hard to go from something like that from
a film that was so artistically
satisfying such a great script and all
these things to go from that to going
back to trying to find work as a doing
more corporate stuff like ice like how
do you even what am I to do
like I circled the drain for a long time
like it it because my life was not
turning out the way I thought it would
and this is everyone's story right
everyone like we all think we know how
it's gonna turn out and life does this
to you and goes back this way and you
know
so for a few years I didn't know my wife
suggested to me maybe we should just
sell everything and go teach English in
Korea and I seriously thought about it
and it got to a point with me where I
had to just it stripped everything away
from me and got me back to the basics of
what do I really love it forced me to
write take another look at what do I
love about the film industry in
filmmaking and storytelling in I found
that spark again like I just I love
moving people and crafting stories and
I'd love to see people laugh when
they're supposed to or jump when they're
supposed like I have worked my whole
life for that if there's no feeling and
no I don't know anything else I couldn't
do anything else and I and I also had to
you know and take it experience and try
to see all the good that came out of it
because a lot of good did he and move
forward which is it's not easy but you
know it yeah that's the other thing they
don't tell you in film school is what
happens when discouragement hits cuz it
does like it can you know especially
when the success doesn't coming when you
think it will you know or it builds up
to it and feels like you're being blamed
or something I mean there is like and I
started this way by saying this there is
we are sold on this idea that the
filmmaking will happen in a certain way
like the Duplass brothers were speaking
at it is film festival years ago what I
saw I read this article somewhere and
they said here's what you do you make
your film for five hundred bucks and
then you get distribution and you make
some money on it then you make your
second film and you put a big star in it
and that'll do well on the festival
circuit yeah well it might happen that
way but it might not for most people
that's not how it happens you'll make
your film and you'll mortgage your house
and then nothing happens that's so
common then I was all the time the film
disappeared on Netflix and that's the
end and now what
and you know you're not discovered and
you're not picked from obscurity and so
then what do you do from there do you
keep going how much do you really love
this how hard are you willing to write
that next script get the next one going
fight for the next client with
everything you've got and fight that
cynicism that wants to just rare it's
ugly little head yeah that's that's
where the love of it will really you
better discover it you better know why
you love it and I do think it's worth
fighting for all the negativity all the
challenges all the frustrations is worth
fighting through to get there because it
really is great like when you're on set
and it's working and you're telling that
story and the actors are there the
cinematography look not it's so like all
of that disappears and just fades away
and you're just like wow I'm creating
this amazing moment and it's working
yeah it's worth fighting for no question
2010 like I mentioned earlier started
with my son getting in an accident I was
getting ready to get ready to shoot my
third film and you know on the day after
his accident basically I literally had
sent my script to my producer that
morning the morning my son was in his
was injured so my assistant director was
already scheduling things and and and
getting things you know starting our
prep and I was supposed to shoot that in
February so you know they were calling
me she was calling me and people were
calling me I wasn't answering my phone
obviously my son was my number one
priority and when I got on like where
the hell are you we got this fit we have
questions about this that in the other
and I called him I said my son was in an
accident he's in ICU and I don't I just
don't have any answers for you again you
have my script you paid me for it if you
want if you guys got to stay with that
schedule just do whatever you want with
it
get another director I don't care
and my producer at the time was knew my
family so he was just like don't worry
about anything
we're ready when you are then they had
that you know they had a deal with
Blockbuster so they had to get movies
out at certain times he's like well
we'll figure it out he said just don't
worry about the movie take care of your
family and just you know keep us posted
on how Julian's doing and that just made
me feel good from a producer to saying
that because I wouldn't I wouldn't have
faulted them if he just said no we're
going to hire another director because
we have a schedule but you know of
course you know stay with your son so it
wasn't till like three weeks after that
accident and he got home that my wife
said go make your movie he's fine and I
said you know I didn't want to go
anywhere really I just wanted to be if
my son she's like you you love this
script you put your heart is his he's
fine he's totally fine you know and go
make your movie so I called my producer
I said that's what's just started on
pre-production he's like we're already
there I said I go did you hire director
he's like nope
we knew we know you're coming back
listen alright so I wouldn't shut my
third film and I edited in Mexico City
when I got back I got told that and this
is the bad year this I got told by an
actor I was working with that he's got
his life story produced he's a bipolar
Golden Gloves boxer who was an actor and
he's got the money from this these two
brothers that wanted to produce his film
and and then when I had gotten back from
Mexico I was told by my producer we had
the money to do your your fourth sounds
like great what's they're all get
started so I started not bartending as
much because I was working so heavily on
two scripts at the same time which I
don't necessarily suggest but they were
what was great about that is when I
would submit an idea for one of the
scripts they would come back to the
producers they didn't like the scene I
would take that scene and put it for my
other strict so I was able to take mix
and match them a little bit that was a
great time but then at the end of that
process like I was ready I was like okay
good let's go I was wanting to quit my
job I wanted that
financing for both these to go through
and then it was there's some skepticism
and then blockbuster went out of
business and that just killed the fourth
the budget for the fourth film so I was
like okay I still have counterpunch and
then those two punks there were
producers decided that they were gonna
use my connections to do their thing and
they didn't want to produce our thing
anymore they were going to do their own
thing and they not doing some
stereotypical really crappy horror thing
that they did so I was just like left
holding this bag and I'm like and I'm
like two months behind on our mortgage
and I'm like I've got to get back to
work so I just threw those both you know
in a bin and I was at work and I was
just like picking up shifts left in
Ryan's working five six shifts a week
and I just was not making enough money
because it was the economy turnaround at
that time and I'm just couldn't catch up
I couldn't catch up man and I just
by the time December rolled around I was
ready to premiere my third my third
feature film it was very ironic because
there's that rally studios and it was
probably the week before that is right
it's very strange when you're doing your
dream but you're your life is kind of
going south right but this is going it's
this weird tug-of-war and I just
remember after telling my wife look I
fucked up
we're losing the house we're gonna have
to move I don't know how aggressive they
are gonna be at coming to take the house
my biggest fear was coming home and
there being a lock in picking on my kids
and there being a lock on our front door
we can't get into our house I guess
we're gonna have to move right after
this shoot right after this the
screening and she was so gracious about
it and I remember sitting outside going
I'm screening my third feature film next
week and I'm losing my house how did I
even fucking get here
and I remember going to rally studios to
test out I was basically at that point
thing and I'm gonna stop after the third
one I'm gonna stop I've given up so much
and sacrificed so much after this third
one I'm done and I remember going to
rally studios and I was gonna do a test
of my hard drive because Louie was on
the hard drive and the projectionist was
there and you know these guys they do
this this is their job they've seen a
million filmmakers come in and they
could care less he just wants to get in
and out we're gonna do it we're gonna do
a test I'm gonna go to every ten minutes
to see if it's okay I'm like okay cool I
go I just have the concern about the
first ten minutes here and then we'll
jump he's like all right so go ahead and
sit down you can call me so I'm sitting
in this rally's studio straining
watching my movie up there and I'm like
this first time I'm seen on the big
screen I've edited a million times on
the small screen but all this it was
just so big in the nuance and the
performances and it was there and I'm
just like watching it going wow I'm
watching it for the first time by myself
in rally studios and before I knew it
I'm like two-thirds the way through and
I haven't heard from the projectionists
and I'm like oh shit I only have like a
half hour to really be there I only have
a half-hour time to test my movie so I
turn around and he's like four rows
behind me watching the movie and I can I
go like this to him and he's like don't
worry about it don't worry about he
starts he's watching my movie he got
into my movie and I just was like it was
a just a great moment and it's such a
dark time for me and I remember going
home going and watched the whole thing
so me and him watched all things I loved
it loved it is I see so much crap come
in here man with he's always your budget
on that and I told him and he's like no
way no way he saw I'm gonna keep my eye
on you I go thanks so much man and and
then you know we had the screening it
was a great screening and it got
distribution and that again it wasn't
enough money by that time I had I was
already gotten another apartment we were
moving out so 2010 ended with us losing
our house and moving and you know having
movies out I was still doing shorts I'm
still writing I was still doing all
those things so then when we moved out
I was pretty much done with filmmaking I
basically said this is too much of a
sacrifice that I put on my family if it
was just me who cares right but yeah I
was tough conversation with my wife and
kids and 2010 sorry 22:28 yeah so we get
the 2011 and it wasn't dire we weren't
homeless you know we I I had three it
was actually a really good lesson in
negotiation particularly if I come
against producers or distributors again
but I had three real estate agents that
were like hawks like rats trying to get
our house and so I basically I emailed
them individually saying I have five
other real estate agents that are
offering me this amount of money to move
out in three weeks whichever one of you
comes with the with the highest number
is the one that's going to get this
house because I had to sign off on on
giving it to them and so I got a good
chunk of money to have a little bit of a
nest day you know I was broke and my
credit was shot everything was shot get
us into a nice apartment and then start
over
sorry just real quick how did they know
that they must have checked the bank
records yeah okay it's a whole racket
man it's a whole racket the banks were
never going to narrow no intention of
helping people keep stay in their homes
because it would have been very easy to
do so I I was like January February of
2011 now and I'm done done my family's
safe we're in a nice place on a balcony
I'm reading a book my producer calls I'm
like what does he want
hey what's up hey man fourth feature is
on we got some money we're gonna go
forward I go no no I'm not doing it and
he's like what do you mean you're not
doing it he's like we love your script
we're gonna go forward to shoot in
Mexico I said no no I'm not doing it
he's like well I go what's the budget
and the budget was just ridiculously low
I go my film can't be shot for that he
said we'll make it happen man he they
were looking out for their comp
they want to stay relevant I go let me
write something else that's smaller no
we can make it we can do it we can do it
and I said alright alright let's do it
and so then it was just hard to cast
because the budget was so low but I was
felt like okay here's my second shot
right I'd have to worry about money at
this point we had money in the bank we
were safe I'm gonna go make another
movie I thought my career was done that
was a bad motivation to go make that
movie because I pulled in some really
great cast and I just didn't do right by
them and that film even though I loved
the process of it it was still
compromising too much for the budget but
we did it and at the end of that I was
in Mexico on our last two nights of
shooting and the producer for the
counterpunch project calls me says where
are you I said in Mexico he's like I got
the funding for counterpunch now you
need to come and interview with these
producers because they're interviewing
directors from CAA and William Morris
and you know all the big agencies and
I'm like no that's my movie man I wrote
it like they're gonna pay for the script
but they don't want you to direct it
well that's bullshit and he says well
when can you get here I go I rap in two
days I'll be there in two days and I go
set up a meeting for Monday I get back
on Sunday he's like okay so I tell my
editor who was with me on set at the
time because he was cutting the movie as
I was shooting that was my normal
process I love to do that haven't had
the luxury of doing that so I said I
told my editor
okay stop what you're doing he's like
what I go stop editing I need you to cut
me a trailer he's like why I go because
our next gig is going to be based on how
good that trailer is he's not serious I
said yeah I go you're coming with me on
that one I go but I need you to cut it
you have 24 hours he's like okay so he's
like cutting the trailer and he's not
working on the movie so my producer on
that film is telling me why isn't the
editor working on the movie he's working
on a trailer already I go well I like
the cast to see what you know how the
things coming together and so they feel
good about what we're doing and he's
like yeah but we're losing time and
money and I said yeah I know but just
let it let us
he's almost done just doesn't finish the
trailer and then he'll get back to
editing it so okay cool so he spends
like two days on this trailer and my
producers pissed and we get into the
room
and he's I need to have a meeting with
you I go okay just a second I bring the
whole cast in we have my own this we're
in this hotel then bring all the whole
cast and crew in there I know Stephen
play the train trailer
plays a trailer and everyone just loses
it a trailer just nails everything I'm
trying to do with this movie and my
producer is very happy so he's like okay
no worries so I get back on Monday I
have that trailer with me and the
producer she's Hungarian very tough this
is a dear friend of mine now she's a
very tough Hungarian woman and I'm
sitting in front and she's like so why
do i why am i meeting with you you're
not with CAA you're not with William
Morris you're not with this you know
that why am I even talking to you we're
gonna pay you as a writer why do you
think you should direct this and I said
well I just shot this film I got back
from I'd love ready to see the trailer
of it what I mean you just shot it I go
I just wrapped it yesterday she's like
yesterday Sunday I said yes and you have
a trailer already and I said yes
let me see it's a turn now she's
watching the trailer and I just said she
had folds my laptop down she looks I
mean she's like okay I go thank you
appreciate your time and she had another
partner actually and then she called me
and said I needed to speak to my partner
first I said sure no problem
it was like a five-minute conversation
after that and I got that gig so I got
that right after I got back from so I
was in post-production
on my fourth and in pre-production on my
fifth and that was my best year man it
was just moviemaking non-stop and yeah
it was great and that the fifth one they
both got distribution the fifth one got
picked up by Lionsgate and was on
Netflix it's actually I just got word
that it's making its China debut this
movie came out five years ago it's
making its China debut in October and
it's UK debut just last month so that
movie still got legs it's a boxing film
it's a genre film so those films kind of
they can go a little bit they go longer
they have a long shelf life so that was
my my worst and best years back to back
yeah I graduated in 2008 and didn't
really I went to business school because
I was filming since I was a kid bought
my first camera and I was 13 but I don't
think it ever really occurred to me that
filmmaking could be a possibility it was
just way too cool for me he like didn't
even it didn't even occur to me that
that was ever going to happen that
didn't even cross my mind so yeah I ran
away from home when I was about 16 and
so there was kind of a pull yourself up
by your bootstraps kind of big
recognition of oh I need to have
stability in my life so when I did go to
college it was for business and focused
on that but went to a liberal arts
school called Fort Lewis College in
Durango Colorado and had amazing
professors that really let me do
whatever I wanted with projects and turn
in videos and it was a great atmosphere
to be in to learn about who I was and
what I wanted to be and after graduating
from there there was just you know not a
lot of jobs it was the the peak of
everyone getting fired from places and
so I decided I would do video production
and that started with you know wedding
videos or tutorials for was really
connected with outdoor industry at that
time so Osprey backpacks and things like
that where they need to do four by three
videos on DP DV tapes and the YouTube
had barely even started so it was just a
different time period and slowly slowly
gained confidence enough to make my
first film and it just kind of took off
from there I had made a film before that
called 23 feet that was about people
living simply to do what they love in
the outdoors and took that on a kind of
unorthodox
tor where the film was called 23 feet
because I was the size of my Airstream
and created a screen that came down from
the Airstream and had an outdoor city
theatre tour where in 30 different
places around the West showed the film
and they out and outside it was places
like you know Tuolumne meadows that said
yosemite - like 30 climbers to a blocked
off street in Portland Oregon with 300
people so it was an amazing very unique
distribution strategy but I just had no
idea about film festivals or anything
like that but what I did find was people
would come up to me after the screenings
or write me letters later about how they
had decided to you know quit their day
jobs and you know empty their Rentals
out and move into a van and decided to
just like you know live the life that
they've always wanted to live and it was
really jolting to get these letters from
people who had decided to change their
life after seeing a film I had made and
really spoke to how powerful films get
me so after that I'd made move shake
which was a series about people who are
dedicating their lives to their passions
of environmental and social justice and
that was a big learning experience but
made several short films and a it was
what led me to making my first feature
in Afghanistan called frame by frame
that was about Afghan photojournalists
and so it's always like getting away
from the outdoor industry and more into
topics that I was interested in around
storytelling yeah I think it's probably
not good to say but I might be the only
person who's thankful for the recession
because it was I think I could have very
easily just gotten a marketing job
somewhere if it would have been a
different time but it really forced me
to think okay I could do a job I really
don't want to do and make OK money or I
could do exactly what I want to do and
push myself and that was
a scary scary risk and leap to take but
really glad it turned out that way
obviously I've been a photojournalist
for a very long time and you kind of try
not to think about it while you're
always thinking how to stay safe this
film was definitely taking a risk you
know the decision going down there is
that we're gonna make a drug war film
that's not gonna be experts it's that's
gonna be talking heads that's gonna put
you in the front row and really make you
feel not learn but really feel what it
feels like to be in Horace to be in this
reality to be in the midst of it so sure
we had a couple of bad runs and I've had
colleagues including Tim Heatherton that
have died but I think you kind of you
know you really concentrate on on being
careful and I'm pushing and doing what
you want and you kind of block out at
the same time this wow this could be
over like that and that was that was
kind of the balance that we struck we
ended up going too far as more than 20
times we always stayed for a very short
time we had our little systems in place
it was a very small two-man crew we try
to not be visible we try to not step on
any wrong toes not open stuff we
shouldn't question crossed your mind why
make a film if it may be my last time no
because and I think that that was
actually Tim's having t'me like he
didn't know where he didn't he barely
knew Libya but you never know when it's
gonna happen if it does and if you
always think that way than us
photojournalist filmmakers I really go
to the front lines we'll never do any of
it because if you live in fear then it's
possible anywhere I could step outside
and something would happen so you gotta
you gotta push everybody has their own
destiny I think because I didn't know
anything I didn't know anything at all
about filmmaking like
I'm glad everything happened the way it
did because I think had out this is me I
think because I didn't know a lot it
made me want to improve so many people
wrong
improvement you know just let people
know like look I can do this I can do
this and the way I got into the film
business is I'm not different business
but into directing was actually I don't
want to say by accident but it was it
was there was a director who promises
that you know I write all these
screenplays and he promised that the
screenplay that option told will be the
next screenplay that he write he didn't
go through with his work and at that
particular time I was emotional about it
I was angry about it but what I did was
I went out and I made my first film yeah
as I look back I'm thankful that he said
no cuz hey he made that first film I
would never probably get on the set and
start to direct but once I got on set to
direct my first film even though I
didn't know anything I don't know
anything about filmmaking I didn't know
what I was doing I knew that this is
where I wanted what I wanted to do so I
don't think that's anything that I wish
I had of known because you know at that
particular time I could say well I wish
I had went to film school but I don't
wish I had more to film school because I
love I love that whole process of
learning as I go along
learning as I make different films in
because it for me for me making it my it
was like I was film school for me and
every time I was I was screening the
film I would get this constructive
criticism not only did it make me a
better filmmaker but that criticism made
me a better human being that I probably
would have received I've had I went to
film school so as I as I got that
criticism I didn't go
I didn't think I would knew everything I
have to listen so when you listen to
able to accept constructive criticism
that does something to you to your
character the thing is is that I think
if I went to film school I probably
thought okay I can't make a film for
five thousand oh if that first film it
was made for like a thousand dollars I
would like I can't make a film for a
thousand dollars you know because in
probably film school I don't know maybe
they're taught that you need a certain
budget but I wasn't thinking about
budget I wasn't thinking about I thought
okay I know I can make a film for $5,000
I know I could make a film for $10,000
so head I want to film school I probably
had that I probably didn't think that
way I probably
okay I need 150,000 to make a film
during that particular time you know and
so that's what I'm saying I'm thankful
that I went in that direction because
you know hey I'm saying I have a
thousand dollars I'm gonna make a movie
you know and uh even though it shot it
was everything we shot in wide shots mom
I'm grateful I'm thankful you know
because the next one we had a medium
shots we had a wide shots we're not
close-ups and then you know and you know
each each project you know I've seen a
you know grow and grow and grow I'm
gonna go get you know I'm always I
consider myself a student filmmaker
because I'm always learning
I'm watching my fam cards I'm watching
the interviews I'm always cuz I've
always considered myself a student
filmmaker and I would never ever escape
that for me to be working full-time and
a pulse house at the vault I think I was
working in about at the time then my
movie came out in black Buster was like
pretty cool I was like the all-star at
the company for it you know for a couple
years or whatever else putting my movies
out and people are trying to figure out
like how how are you doing this right
how did you shoot it moving you're
working here full time and I just didn't
sleep a lot you know but yeah I found a
ways to shoot like three movies without
losing my job at the pulse house center
site and use a lot of my vacation so
strategic with my vacation days and I
remember working night shift as a film
and recording operator and I remember
staying up almost a period almost eight
days straight like I stayed up three
days straight and then went to sleep and
then stayed up another three days
straight and I went to sleep because
they my company went let me take time
off but I worked a night shift so I just
got my mind mentally mentally stabilized
that I want to stay up because they told
me if I if I didn't direct my if I was
unable to direct my movies and get
another director but the movie wasn't
paying me enough to quit my job so I had
to make sure I kept my job my post job
which was obviously paying and paying
all my bills and everything and it's one
movie it was my third or second movie
called sweet potato pie remember that
but um but yeah I remember working the
night shift and I remember the way I
worked it out I got off at 6:00 in the
morning and I had call time at 8:00 in
the morning so I literally stayed up I
started I remember started I made sure I
started to shoot on a Wednesday because
I was off on a weekend so I stayed at
Wednesday Thursday Friday straight I
don't know how I did it but my whole
system was get off at work at 6 a.m. go
home shower and I was ready for 8:00
a.m. call time didn't I work from 8:00
a.m. when it set from 8 a.m. to 8 p.m.
and then I was able to take a nap for an
hour or so to get to work for 10 p.m.
because I worked from 10:00 p.m. to 6
a.m. and I did that literally for three
days straight and I remember and only
way I stayed up was I had something to
do every second every minute for the
last 36 hours like the job that I had
and tennis I required me to be attentive
me with the computer and with these film
ounce can outs and I was on coffee but I
remember having my friend videotape me
as proof that you know I was pulling off
this miraculous situation with directing
the movie to end up going to line ski
but my first movie then went some lines
again I'm just working and working and
scanning and recording at the time is
like mm 2 or 3
you know yeah but yeah it was a crazy
feeling when you're passionate and
dedicated and you have a chance an
opportunity and I chose to achieve both
I'm like man I can't quit my job for was
only I was making under ten thousand
dollars or something for doing a movie
he should have been way more than that
but um but yeah that was a pretty
interesting situation when I when I
pulled up the movie sweet potato pie
when I was 23 I was a story editor of
the series
General Motors theater and the man who
produced it Cindy Newman
he said to me one day you know Ted you
know I was doing a lot of rewriting it
was a great training because people
directors we should I'm 10 minutes sharp
I need two scenes right I'd write two
scenes and and then but after about a
year of this the producer was sitting
you in Kevin said to me you know 10
you're pretty good writer
not a great writer but a pretty good
writer but I know but I know one thing
you really would be a good great ad and
I said what's that he said you'd be a
great director now why'd you say this I
never asked him why he said this he said
here's what I'm gonna do
I'd like you to do you're gonna do one
show for me live television drama if I
like it I'll give you a year's contract
if I don't like it you're up the street
you can't come back to this job I said
I'll risk it he said if you don't want
to risk it you you can stay on because
you're doing a great job it's a story
editor and I said no no I want to be a
director I'll risk it and so he allowed
me to direct and of course I worked my
butt off getting it every shot because
it had a good life I wanted to be a
director and here I was being given a
chance to be a director how many offers
will you get of that kind in your whole
life so it's just I'll let you direct so
I rely just had to grab I'm not
interested in a job I was interested in
being a director so you had to take it
it was an opportunity it was being
offered to you it would be silly to
refuse it oh it's very easy to be a
independent filmmaker in India because
all are the very few studios that
outright they've come from the West one
or two Indian companies are doing it
they they are studios the rest are all
independent films it's very easy to be
an independent producer I am an
independent producer not reliant on any
studio facilities but think when things
go wrong it goes drastically wrong for
an independent filmmaker we would rather
that we had somebody taking all the risk
for us we are taking it all ourselves
this some of the films don't even have
insurance things go wrong they go down
it's like bungee jumping we try to check
the cards but it can never be sure I bet
all the money I have most of the time if
the film doesn't do I start from scratch
again I've done it a couple of times I
don't enjoy it very much and you're able
to sleep at night oh yes because to
begin with I never had this money
everything else was bonus so I can't
complain the whole theme to this whole
journey that we have been honest
filmmakers and and the band has been on
and Arnelle has been on it's truly one
that you could easily say with a theme
of don't stop believin I mean um
you know I know has been doing it for a
very long time and journey has been
around for a very long time and I was
always a big journey fan and I always
thought they were big and they were
always big and they're always gonna be
big but when you you get into any kind
of dive into it you realize that no
they're just like anyone else any one's
life they have ups and downs and highs
and lows and you know Neil never stopped
believing in his band
John Jonathan Kaye never stopped
believing and I know
never start stopped believing and we as
filmmakers like never stopped believing
it's like really a theme
and you know we kind of jumped out there
on her own credit cards we didn't have
funding in place and everything and the
first time I saw a little clip that
Ramona put together I said we have to do
this and she's like well they're on tour
right now and I said right now we were
standing in a Starbucks parking lot she
said yeah I said we're missing a story
it's unfolding like we have to go now
and she's like well we don't have money
and I said well we can't let that stop
us
don't let that suffice so within a week
of that conversation we were on the road
just like stuff on credit cards and and
we just always knew and there was one
moment you know because we were so small
and we didn't have a lot of money there
was only five of us on a road so there's
two camera operators one sound Ramona
and myself and my job was are sort of to
to PA and you know to drive and just
dump footage and just do kind of all the
things anything else that you know
needed to be done and I remember at one
point we were probably like maybe at the
six venue and I was sitting back there
and it kind of dawned on me I said we're
like charging up a storm
we're following a rock band we don't
have any money we don't know what the
movie is we don't know anything we're
just out here and I watched like ten
minutes of our now in the dressing room
and he would captivated me I couldn't
take my eyes off of him and that's when
I knew I was like we're gonna be all
right
like I knew we're gonna be all right so
we were in a minivan it was five of us
all our luggage for the summer all our
gear and we would just follow this band
I mean these big you know tour buses
these big semis and just kind of keep up
with them and it never occurred to me
before like what am i doing cuz you know
you're kind of on adrenaline and and you
just be you just like get it done get it
done get it done but that's then once
you're getting it done and you're doing
it then you kind of sit back and go what
am i doing so that was like the first
time and it was the last time I
questioned it it was probably about
three years I had an idealism that I
write the script and it be a David
Sedaris thing the first and probably
only port David Sedaris project and my
thing was so okay even though it's a
little tar cannot be people are gonna
want to make it you know people are
gonna make this and make it and a
higher-end indie budget lot
you know like a few million and it was
night it was a little naive on my hand
to think that you know I was putting a
lot of restrictions on it you know I
think when you're going for money you
need to know what how willing how where
are your priorities for me my priority
wasn't controlling the material keeping
the script the same and and being able
to decide on having you know the final
say on casting like those are the kind
of things that aren't gonna push
investors away it's not to say they'd
have embraced all those things anyone
were to jumped on board ultimately I'm
making a movie that was dealing with
religious themes themes sexuality you
know stuff that isn't necessarily every
time I see him an independent film or
like I don't know how they got it
financed and I mean I always feel it as
a compliment you know especially see
ones made like been like how did that
happen I think every single film finds
its own way and usually that way is
totally different than the previous way
you know I mean this this was it was
just a long process of really getting a
lot of knows at one point I think I
calculated it was like it sorry once it
got like over like a hundred fifty nose
or so I just I stopped counting like I
kept a running chart and when it was
like hit that many of people like
financed ears or producers or companies
production companies that have passed on
it then I just like stopped keeping a
number tally because I got a little
depressing you know I feel like I have a
thick skin but I think it's okay for
anyone to feel like 150 rejections on
the same script is a little it convene
at all mind-numbing you know but um it
was you know but it was about I thought
the system would sort of serve me a
little better like I thought well I've
made my first film and people saw it and
people liked it and now I've written the
script and it's a well-known author and
I have agents and it's gonna it'll it'll
come together in the way it should and
it was kind of wrong for me to feel that
way because ultimately it came together
through whatever resources I sort of
engaged and build and so I had support
from you know film independent that I
had on my own that I had built over over
the years and they I got brought into a
program where I met a producer who came
on board the
financing you know some of those things
that ended up being through my own path
and not to say it as anything negative
towards the agency route but just to say
that like at no point should you ever
just sort of be like okay well now I
have rats and they're gonna get it all
taken care of like you know at the end
of the day you're only you're always
responsible for yourself and I think
financing is no different just about
always staying on top of anyone you know
anyone who might know someone with money
and just always sting persistent on it
and and keep on pushing and keep on
pushing because it's it's gonna
everyone's gonna say no I mean rarely do
I really ever heard a story where
someone was like I was really accept the
script out people liked it we got a bed
like it that maybe happens with genre
films but I don't think it ever happens
with a drama or comedy or especially not
a dark comedy you know two things I do
have a group of friends that have sort
of gone away while I've been progressing
in my career now my career is still not
where I want it to be but just there was
there was even a time when I got to do
my first direct my first feature there
were two people that like just were
there in my life but they I could see
they pulled back like there was
something about what they sort of their
decisions were sort of taking him a
different Road they were the ones that
were way more talented than me I mean
both of them still are both of them are
better directors better writers like I
think they're better but they sort of
get in their own way and you know I
found myself having to pull away because
there was no sort of like the love
wasn't you know like I wanted them to be
as excited as I was for them when they
had things happening and it wasn't and I
was like oh that's interesting and now
you know this is you know about four
years later and it's like those guys are
not in my life anymore and it's tough I
mean I try to keep trying and I was at
one point is like I'm the only one
texting tech dude
take a look what do you got you know
what I mean and then they'd meet and
then it's just like yeah you know and
it's just like Oh where's the no
excitement for what we're doing together
you know so it's tough it's time in this
business I mean it's brutal
I started at 15 I started writing
directing shooting crafting and editing
you know I started a really early
shooting on Betamax and so the way I
figured out how to create an editing
system for my films was I would take two
Betamax machines put them together
pop pop the raw food like I'd shoot on
Betamax and I popped out that that raw
footage in the top player on the bottom
player I put an empty tape in there and
so and running all through the
television and so I would use the pause
and play button to actually cut on my
short onto the onto the empty tape you
know so I learned to get really precise
because if you make a mistake you have
to start all over again and recut the
whole thing so I used like two Betamax
machines to edit and then I ran a boom
box into the Betamax machines into the
television and I had like all my
cassette tapes kind of queued up with
music and I would have to at the exact
moment I would have to pop the tape in
and play it and record the music onto my
short films you know so I just kind of
cooked cooked up this elaborate way to
make these short films these little
five-minute ten-minute little shorts and
I was sort of out of necessity I was
sort of used to doing everything myself
I would have to write the short I would
use my friends and we would sit on the
weekends and then throughout the week
you know would edit and put the music on
and bothered by the next weekend I would
have like a short film everybody sit
around and watch it it's interesting
dude is like the first camera I bought
like so in 15 I'll put this camera on
layaway it was a it was Japanese this
Betamax camera it wasn't in English so
nobody wanted it you know and so hum
that was the only reason I could afford
it is because it was so cheap because
nobody would buy this thing and so I
bought it I took it home and then I made
myself like a table of contents like I
would push a button and see
what it does and then whatever that
whatever it did I would just write that
down like oh okay that must be rewind
and this must be play and this must be
you know and sort of like made myself a
table of contents to use the camera
until I learned all the symbols and
learn what they did and yeah that's how
I started making my first choices with
this Japanese camera that nobody wanted
you know what store was this where you
put it online
oh it was a pawn shop okay old-school
pawnshop but there were some interesting
stories behind that camera yeah it's
like 11 months to get that camera every
little bit of money I got I would just
put on this camera and you know the
truth is I think that that balance is
never perfect I often joke that what I
think doesn't get talked about enough is
that the stage of light loose that I'm
in right now is I don't know that I'd do
anything as well as I wish that I could
but I'm just trying to get all of it to
at least be pretty good being a dad
being a professor being a husband being
a filmmaker they all had their demands
every one of them is awesome I wouldn't
give up any of them but know for sure
making this movie is one of the most
difficult who's ever done and I don't
say that actually looking for pity but
more like I think they just should be a
more candid acknowledgement of how hard
it is to balance those things you know
for part of this movie I was like I was
a part-time professor part-time
stay-at-home dad and trying to make a
feature and then you know now I'm a full
professor at full-time professor at
Occidental and you know I have two kids
now instead of one when I started and
for sure yeah like that balance is
difficult in so many ways in terms of
just time when can you get free to do it
in terms of just resources you know
those other things there's just spending
money and that sort of stuff and then
we're generally the the hardest one I
find is the shift in mindset that if I
were to really encapsulate the phase of
life I'm in right now it's having to
shift gears and sort of take off
different hats and put different hats on
with no real transition points so to go
from dad to Professor to filmmaker
it's a dad you know around that there's
no mental space to sort of flip over and
I'm just
cept I think I just wear it where I am
right now and I think there's this image
of like filmmaking that is almost like
it's divorced from the rest of life but
again you know I think that this is the
reality of independent cinema and every
filmmaker I know knows this I actually
we should talk about it more which is to
say if you were feeling like man it's
really hard to like you know pack that
lunch for the kid and then they go to
your job and Mikey's like teeth this
lesson correctly and then make it to set
on time and shoot this shot having
remembered everything you needed and
being in a state of mind to be creative
if you're like that's difficult I want
to say like yeah it is difficult and I
don't know who we're kidding if we're
saying it's not and and and to me like
and that's fine like I think that like
that struggle is a reality and so I'm
just trying to maximize it and optimize
it but I don't think it's gonna go hey I
was also working at a sandwich shop
which was my second job I ever had and
actually my last straight job I ever had
and when I was working there I making
sandwiches and then going to these film
classes at SMC and you know the first
thing first day of class we're sitting
in me in the class we watch No Country
for Old Men and the teacher goes okay
and what did you guys think of it and
nobody raises their hand so I raised my
hand and I start talking about the
nihilistic themes in the film and really
getting in-depth into it and then the
teachers like excited it's the first day
and he's like yeah this is great
what are you guys thinking everybody
it's like quiet and then like one girl
slowly raises her hand and goes I liked
it and everybody was like oh yeah I
liked it too oh yeah he was a that guy
in uh he was really good the Javier
Bardem or whatever and I was I was like
um I was trying to talk about like real
stuff in the movie and so I I just
didn't like being there so they had a
thing where you know they assigned it in
the beginning of the year that by the
end of the year you had to eat
write a script or make a short film or
something like that and you have to
write like a short script and so I
started writing a short script and I
really liked the short script and I
started writing it into a feature script
and then I finished the feature script
and my pure joy and I just started
hitting up friends of mine going hey I
want to make this movie all I need is
$7,000 $7,000 is all I need to make it
that's all that Robert Rodriguez had to
do el Mariachi I'll try and make it work
so I tried to get seven grand and I
ended up talking to my friend and then
business partner later Jarrett Cohen and
he gave me the seven grand to make the
movie and I remember I I just stopped
going to school dropped out to make the
movie because I couldn't deal with their
schedule and I was working at the
sandwich shop and I remember they called
me and they're like hey we need you to
come into work today and I was like I
can't do that you know I I'm I need to
do pre-production on this movie and
they're like well do they're like like
is it a real movie and I was like yeah
it's a real movie it's like a low-budget
indie I'm it's seven thousand dollar
budget and the guy laughs and he goes
well you got to ask yourself do you want
to make a small little indie film or do
you want to have a job and I was like I
want to make a small little indie film
piece and I hung up the phone and never
went back and I haven't had a regular
job since and kind of like two mortal
eyes that I got life tattooed on my
knuckles which some people thought was
stupid because they thought it was like
I don't like thug life but for me it was
you can't get a restaurant job or a
straight job when you have tattoos on
your knuckles and so it was for me it
was getting rid of my fallback meaning
that this is my life
this is what I'm gonna do and if I leave
a fallback for myself any time things
get hard I'm gonna try and go to the
fallback and things get hard they really
do but as long as you don't have a
fallback you know that you got to keep
pushing forward and hustling and I think
I think you know I I talked with Wes
Craven once when we were working on
something and he he said that and I
really took it to heart
filmmaking isn't judged by how great of
a filmmaker you are a career in
filmmaking is judged by the ability to
persevere if you believe in yourself as
a filmmaker and keep pushing forward
against all odds those are the people
that change things those are the people
that actually do and I want to be a doer
and I want to keep pushing forward and I
believe that you know it's not always an
easy road I grew up with my dad being a
writer he was you know the head writer
on Pinky and the brain and Animaniacs he
won three Emmys and a WGA award and I
remember sometimes we had a lot of money
and sometimes I didn't get presents for
the holidays and it's because there's
ups and downs and as long as you can
ride it out and choose to persevere and
go through it you'll do okay
truth be told probably learn more from
the films that didn't get made thinking
back on why they didn't get made what
could I have done different but of the
films that got made which are the ones
people know a bit more hopefully I would
say the moth Mothman Prophecies which
was another Richard Gere film was and
there was one moment one seminal moment
and and again that was a film that that
had been shot all over town every
company independent medium big studio
all passed on it I wasn't involved at
the time the agent shop did the writer I
hadn't produced before I was the I
actually got to produce his first film
and he came to me and said would you
read this and I fell in love with it and
his and and then I learned it had been
passed on and I found there was one
company and only one company that hadn't
seen it that was Lake Shore a wonderful
company so I said you know what I will I
will invest time in this and I will take
it to lakeshore and
and I knew it was that was it there was
literally one buyer in the whole world I
can sell this to so I went to them and
they read it three eggs a q-tips and
they called me the following Monday
morning typical Monday morning call
right brilliant story
we loved the craft it was intriguing
based on a true story oh my god
fascinating beautiful beautiful
beautiful responses from all of them
at which point one of them said so
thanks so much for sending it over it's
gonna be passed only in Hollywood and I
thought that wait a minute I'm sorry did
you just say it's gonna be past all this
all the Haldeman you you're you know all
this laudatory language and then you're
dead
and there was long pause cuz I knew this
was it this was the last man standing
there was no other option and that was
the company I mentioned this earlier
that was the company at the moment when
I said I respectfully pass on your past
and there was some nervous laughter I
said look of course you can ask but
based on our relationship and our
respect for one another
I would ask that before you make a final
final final decision let me just come in
and talk to you so I I went to this
meeting I told these three executives
the story of my relationship with my dad
why because the script when I read it
initially was so moving to me because
the character played by Richard Gere is
so lost in grief after his beloved young
wife dies and a lot of what the texture
of it was reminiscent to me of what I
felt after my dad's death he was my best
friend and and to me this film was a
great film in its own right and it
deserved to get made and more
importantly it would be a private amage
to my dad and so I care deeply about it
so I went into this meeting with three
people who'd read it ins and said nice
things about it but passed on it and so
I thought the door was open just a
little bit and I never referenced the
script I never talked about the title I
just simply told the story of my dad I
told who my dad was I talking about our
friendship and our relationship and the
love that we had and what it was like
when unexpectedly
I'm sick he just passed away what that
was to my family in debate and I just
spent not long 12 minutes 10 minutes
telling the story at the end of which I
simply said I cannot imagine anyone
don't make her actor audience doesn't
matter who will not be moved where why
are whether we lost someone or not were
wired to understand the tragedy and
despair of losing someone so close to
you and they cuddled and they changed
their mind bottom line they changed
their mind and we got to make this film
and it's a great film it wasn't as big
as pretty woman but but it was well
received in acts I become more popular
over over over the years and I'm very
proud of the film but in a way as a
learning lesson is like you know we
talked earlier about never take no for
an answer
and I think what I came away from that
was if you are you know if you're ballsy
enough if you're bold and courageous
enough just do this like get naked in
public if you're willing to get naked in
public people are impressed right
because we all know about vibration and
frequency and when if you're like you
know when you're deeply moved and you're
in that very deeply authentic place and
and there's no BS we know it it's real
that's very attractive to us and that's
what we want to put on a big screen and
that's what they got they got why this
is gonna move the audience and therefore
potentially be a success and the film
was successful as a business matter but
I that's now you know it I don't measure
it in those terms I just think how do I
get a yes from these people so I can do
what I so desperately want to do as a
creative person and and the only thing I
could do is tell the truth and
it worked it was on always my dream to
make movies and it was always my dream
to be a Hollywood director but that was
kind of like a secret because I'm you
know I'm from Sweden and it's like the
other side of the world like I don't
have any like family members who are in
show biz or anything like that so I
might like you can say to friends and
family like yeah I'm gonna be a hold of
director because people are gonna be
like yeah sure like I'm gonna be the
king of Spain whatever you know but that
was always the goal and then it's been
you know a lot of times that goal has
felt really far away and I've been very
depressed and and felt like oh this is
never gonna happen of course but that
was always the goal like that was what I
wanted to do with my life so in a way
it's been you know you can't say that
it's been expected but it's always been
the goals it's always been like yeah
that's what I really want so I turned
around and he's like four rows behind me
watching the movie and I can I go like
this to him and he's like not I don't
worry about don't worry about he starts
he's watching my movie he got into my
movie and I just was like it was a just
a great moment and it's such a target
time for me and I'm ever going to I'm
going and we watched the whole thing so
me and him watched all things like loved
it loved it is I see so much crap come
in here man with he's all what was your
budget on that and I told him and he's
like no way no way
he saw I'm gonna keep my eye on you I
don't thanks so much man and I do think
it's worth fighting for
all the negativity all the challenges
all the frustrations is worth fighting
through to get there because it really
is great like when you're on set and
it's working and you're telling that
story and the actors are there the
cinematography look not it's so like all
of that disappears and just fades away
and you're just like wow I'm creating
this amazing moment and it's working
yeah it's worth fighting for no question
filmmaking isn't judged by how great of
a filmmaker you are a career in
filmmaking is judged by the ability to
persevere if you believe in yourself as
a filmmaker and keep pushing forward
against all odds
those are the people that change things
those are the people that actually do
and I want to be a doer and I want to
keep pushing forward and I believe that
you know it's not always an easy road I
grew up with my dad being a writer he
was you know the head writer on pinky in
the brain and Animaniacs he won three
Emmys and a WGA Award and I remember
sometimes we had a lot of money and
sometimes I didn't get presents for the
holidays and it's because there's ups
and downs and as long as you can ride it
out and choose to persevere and go
through it you'll do okay I think it's
probably not good to say but I might be
the only person who's thankful for the
recession because it was I think I could
have very easily just gotten a marketing
job somewhere if it would have been a
different time but it really forced me
to think okay I could do a job I really
don't want to do and make okay money or
I could do exactly what I want to do and
push myself and that was a scary scary
risk and leap to take but really glad it
turned out that way obviously after
having had a horrible year getting
clobbered in my lawsuit against Chevron
I had you know the opposite experience
where I saw the power of documentaries
that you know films can affect positive
social change that they had a deep
impact on on the West Memphis Three case
and thankfully that renewed my spirit
and I got out of my doldrums and I you
know carried on I learned from the
experience and I think I understood that
it's gonna be hard if not impossible to
get what you want out of this business
unless you really have the ability to
push through those moments when it's the
hardest thing for you in the world and
you feel like just crushed if you can
push past that I think you have what it
takes to stay in this industry that's
another level of confidence that doesn't
happen without adversity so if you
achieve something in a moment of
darkness how much easier is the light
how much easier is sunrise like just you
know we've got we've gotten through it
so we could do it again if you do it
again
we could do it again so in those moments
of weakness or in those moments where
things are going bad I know that I'm not
gonna crumble you can't give up you just
it's the it's it's it's the blessing and
curse of this industry you know you it's
it's it's a blessing and a curse I mean
you keep going because you're passionate
you're gonna get it done you know but
it's not painless and then when someone
sees what you see and they have
distribution and they say it has value
tears and I don't mean the polite time
Yunus the snotty type you know that kind
of stuff that really just thankful
you